all right guys bang-bang I have to man
the myth the legend himself what's going
on John
I love the bangbang man that's my thing
too I just for the record John's the
first person ever start the podcast off
with finger guns we're already into the
finger guns we're ready to rock and roll
so for for like the one person watching
this who doesn't know who you are never
see you on television
let's go through your background kind of
where where'd you grow up and what you
do before you got into financial markets
sure Popeye I grew up in the Bay Area
San Francisco lived there till I was 12
loved it we used to go down to Haight
Ashbury and drive around and check out
the freaks as we used to call him that
was before I became politically correct
now I would just call him hippies but we
always had a good time
and you know it was never a heckling
thing or anything else we would just my
dad's at the doctor and so that's where
I took my nickname from dr. J from my
dad more or less to honor him but when
he was a surgeon in San Francisco and an
Assistant Chief of Surgery there he
would have people fly in from all over
the world to learn various surgical
techniques because he was one of the
first people to successfully do liver
transplants pancreas transplants things
like that
so he would teach people from all over
the world and since then Francisco and
Haight Ashbury was kind of top of mind
for a lot of people they'd say hey can
we go down and see the hippies so my dad
would say boys get in the car we're
going down but make sure you roll up the
windows cuz those guys ever have lice
but so we would drive down to Haight
Ashbury and you know it would look
exactly like you think it would look a
bunch of wonderful
Victorian homes lots of men and women
with long hair big glasses day or night
you know big sunglasses and you know
monster bell-bottom jeans and things
like that exactly what you think it
would look like that is what it looked
like and San Francisco you know the city
by the bay I loved it
I I went back there briefly to Berkeley
for school to the University of
California because we moved when I was
12 pumped to Minneapolis my dad took a
job as chief of surgery at the
University of Minnesota so we moved to
Minneapolis loved that because there was
snow and season changes San Francisco
it's pretty much the same around its you
know it's cold and foggy in the morning
and then it gets cold and foggy again in
the evening but in between it could be
sunny or rainy and it was just a fun
city I loved growing up there and then
when we went to Minnesota like I say we
had very harsh changes in the season
from fall - all of a sudden 60 below you
know a month later so the season change
was a big deal but that was also no fun
and I got to go - lets see high school
with Prince and a bunch of these famous
musicians that they weren't famous in
high school they were just interesting
fellows because I got bust into a mostly
black high school so I went from
lily-white San Francisco lily-white
junior high school - all of a sudden
being bused into an all-black high
school and it was a little not scary but
you know you were always on edge so I
bet I know how a lot of
african-americans or blacks feel when
they go to an all-white high school you
know they probably are on edge - but
some of my greatest friends and
friendships were made you know
from that and back then yeah we had
gangs but the gangs didn't shoot you pop
you know the gangs worst case scenario a
gang would beat you up now you didn't
want that but you know I played football
so all the guys on the team were my
friends but they weren't gonna walk me
home every day so I had to frequently
run from the football you know from
showering up after football practice
kind of looking both ways and making a
dash to get to a safer neighborhood
because if I got caught in the wrong
neighborhood again I think it builds
kind of a empathy for somebody who would
be the opposite you know like I say for
an African American or Asian kid that
was in an all-white school where they
didn't feel so comfortable walking
through that neighborhood either but
like I say it ended up working out great
I have enjoyed both the friendships and
the experience of not being in the high
school that I thought I would have been
in yeah that's awesome and then what you
guys do for for cause because you have a
twin brother correct you guys are twins
no no everybody thinks that though and
not everybody but a lot of people say oh
you must be twins nope six years apart
really yep Pete is the youngest of four
boys I am the oldest
so I'm six years older than Pete four
years older than Paul and two years
older than Dave so you don't know this
but I am the oldest of five boys I am
eight years older than the youngest and
everyone in between his two years apart
so very similar we just have one more
than you do what are the two brothers in
the middle doing one brother David he
sold a bunch of fast-food franchises
that he started with my brother Paul and
now he runs a health club that he owns
he owns this big building you know
that's got a health club so that
been challenging of course during Kovac
because by law they had to stay
shuttered and he has several ice cream
parlors and he kills it with the ice
cream
he's only open in the summer but he
absolutely kills it you know they're
scooping out these gigantic you know
scoops of ice cream and people come from
all over the city
to his ice cream shops because they over
serve so much and the other ones sadly
passed away of ALS so that was really a
crappy thing my brother Paul passed away
now five years ago of ALS got it sorry
to hear that
and why wife yeah absolutely and why
didn't you and the youngest why the kind
of bookends if you will want to go into
the financial markets whereas your other
brothers one more into entrepreneurship
well I did it because I was playing
football for the Bears and that's what
brought me to Chicago I was not a high
draft choice or anything like that i was
free age which meant that just for the
folks that don't know if you're not
drafted you can go to any team that
offers you a contract so i had three
teams that offered me a serious contract
discussions with a couple other teams i
ended up picking the bears because i
thought you know what they have a really
crappy team no but you know think about
it it's just like do you do you wanna if
you're gonna join and try to beat
somebody out for a job do you want to go
to Apple where everybody's a killer you
know where all those engineers or
killers or do you want to go to a shitty
[Music]
place where you're you might be as good
as any of the engineers they have you
know that was my that was how I did it
pop with you know weighing do I want to
be
you know do I want to try to play for
New England you know where their Super
Bowl champ kind of things or do I want
to go to a team where they haven't been
anywhere forever they suck and the
linebackers aren't that good that was my
position linebacker and so and that's
you know both cockiness on my part me
thinking oh I'm better than those
professionals which I wasn't but I do
think that you'd want to pick a place
where you think you might be able to
make the team if you're drafted you
don't get that choice you just you know
you go and if if you're a high round
draft pick you're gonna make it
you know nobody cuts their first-round
pick until the second year or third year
but you know as far as free agent it was
great brought me to Chicago so when I
learned the ropes my brother Pete who
was like I say six years younger he was
still in high school so you know cuz I
came right after college he's still in
high school
he's deciding where he's gonna go play
college football and after he was an
all-american and a big star at
University of Minnesota he went down and
he played for Seattle
the Seahawks then he played for the
Vikings then he played for Tampa Bay
then he played for the Raiders and each
time in the offseason he'd come and
visit me here in Chicago and he'd always
say god it really has a cool energy a
cool vibe down here on the floor and I
said yeah it does you know that's why I
love it that's why you know 3,000 men
and women on the floor that's why they
love it but it's also I'm sure you see
this all the time there are probably
people who are so into blockchain and
crypto or digital assets but they're
into it because they want to make a lot
of money you're into it because you can
make money but also you're into it
because you love it there are probably
every year give or take seven hundred to
a thousand people that
of the floor and they don't leave
because they retired with a big pile of
money you know they left because they
couldn't pack it they couldn't make it
so that churn just stays there all the
time so of the 3,000 people 2,000 of
them are probably happy and a thousand
of them are probably churning and
leaving and coming back and you know
trying to get refunded and all that
stuff so you know if you are somebody
who finds that fun and exciting and you
know that's why pop I'm always pumping
my fist on TV or you know shooting the
guns or whatever bang bang because you
know it just it I'll I enjoy what I do
and I know you do because you know we've
talked and I've seen the people that you
know come to your events and things like
that the people that just love they they
actually love the idea not just the idea
of getting rich the idea of getting rich
that's really an easy sell well but it's
a little harder to get excited about
actually doing this every day and making
this a you know your vocation it's one
of these weird things where when you
talk to people who seem to be successful
and you ask them why do you do what you
do majority of the people I've talked to
will answer some form or fashion up I
enjoy the process of this write it the
product or kind of the end result takes
care of itself right it's kind of a
football way of thinking of like hey
look we got to do every single play and
as long as everyone does their job every
offensive play is drawn up to be a
touchdown and every defensive play is
john up to stop them for a loss right
and it really just comes down to kind of
the process and execution all this kind
of stuff and so it feels like that
people who end up being successful they
enjoy that process and it's the process
or kind of showing up every single day
for year after year after year that's
what ultimately leads them to the
success into your point the people who
either don't enjoy it can't you know
hack it or whatever it is the other ones
you kind of wash out and go do find
other things to do in life right yeah
that's exactly right and and you can't
really some people will kind of sell
their soul to be an investment banker or
you know
some other job in finance that their
heart isn't really in it and they do it
for a couple years maybe they make just
enough but they're always looking for a
way out and I was never looking for a
way out I was looking to stay in as long
as I could but you know the game changes
and you know every financial edge that
people think they have goes away
eventually
and you have to develop something new
that doesn't mean you can't own you know
Bitcoin or aetherium or Microsoft or
Apple forever you could but if you're
trying to make a you know a living day
by day trading in and out you know and
all the sudden computer algorithms are
taking all the edge away it's a little
tougher for sure so when you ended up
deciding to leave the NFL what did you
do it first did you go right to the
trading pits or kind of what was that
journey like and what was kind of the
impetus for going into that environment
sure it's a it is a very good questions
because a I didn't leave of my own
volition they fired me they cut me and
you know it was one of those deals pop
where literally they come to your door
knock on the door and I know I'm gonna
get cut tomorrow I know I'm gonna get
cut and they'd leave because they
couldn't face that and when it happened
to me I was pretty sure that I was gonna
be cut but I was still in enough of
denial you know the river in Egypt where
I thought well you know a couple of
these other guys left maybe they need an
extra linebacker to hang around before
Singletary you know what if he hurts
himself or whatever he never did the guy
was like unstoppable and that's the guy
that beat me out Mike Singletary so he
did a great job he was very good guy too
so it would be easy to hate the guy that
you know that takes the job from you but
this guy was just such a good guy you
couldn't hate him and I've always been a
guy also that's pretty honest with
myself as far as my abilities
so when I meet somebody who is better
than me could be in trading you know
I've met guys that are better than me it
could be in skiing and it happened to be
in football you know and I was just like
yeah I get it he's better than me and
the coach was like yeah we're sorry you
know not everybody can make you know how
it is John blah blah blah and I'm like
hey man I appreciate the opportunity
thank you yeah that's awesome and I mean
look to be completely Frank Wright
playing linebacker for Chicago Bears no
matter how long it was is is one of
mazing and then two to hang out and meet
with guys like my Singletary and kind of
all of the players that went through
that organization is obviously life
experienced a lot of people won't have
right yeah I agree
and luckily I had one bad injury in high
school and nothing after that so you
know I've seen guys with their shoulders
cut their knees cut their hands my
brother Pete has broken every finger at
least once and his thumbs twice so yeah
there's a lot of injuries and things
that guys get that i luckily avoided
yeah that's awesome and and so help me
understand as you decide okay I'm gonna
go kind of build a career in finance and
trading did you already know people and
kind of have a back-up plan was it like
okay I got cut and now all of a sudden I
gotta go figure this out like what what
happened kind of post getting cut from
the NFL that eventually launched the the
career in finance again that's a great
question because since my dad was a
doctor and he was pretty famous I mean
in his field he was you know like at if
not the zenith you know right up there
on the top of the mountain he developed
a bunch of anti-rejection drug
for people when they got transplants and
things like that so he was very famous
and he's the chief surgery at the
University of Minnesota for like 38
years so the choices were I could go up
there but I could stay there but I'd
always be in his shadow I thought and no
shame in that but I wanted to kind of
forge my own path and so my agent was
putting some of his representative
players because he had hockey players
skiers baseball players that kind of
stuff
I mean famous people like Rod Carew and
Allan page they were his clients so he
was putting some of those guys on the
trading floor because they had what he
thought was necessary to be successful
in trading they were disciplined they
were excitable they were physical and he
thought those kinds of things would make
you a good trader now he knew you of
course you needed to learn that all the
other stuff too but if you didn't have
those things
some people were putting like
professional blackjack players on the
floor because if you can count cards you
can be a pretty good trader and I agree
that's a good skill I knew a guy that
could count three decks of cards and you
know beat you on virtually every hand
beat and he was banned he had to you
know when he'd go to Vegas or Reno he'd
have to go in a wig and things like that
I mean you know they he was kicked out
of more casinos but he was not good in
the pit even though he was a good trader
because he wasn't aggressive enough and
so like I say my agent was looking for
guys that were aggressive that could
learn the other stuff some of these guys
were like professional chess players you
know grandmasters in chess and you might
imagine that you and I probably know
guys Tom that are like that they tend
not to be terribly aggro
you know it's all up here and so they'd
put on a position and they'd walk away
and you know hopefully they'd put on
enough edge that they could make money
from putting that position on but they
couldn't stand down there in the pit and
grind it out like the rest of us could
because they weren't aggressive enough
it's a physical you know back then
anyway it was very physical you couldn't
hit people but you could throw elbows
and things like that people didn't want
you standing in their spot so being
bigger I'm still about 6 2 and 215 back
then I was 6 to maybe 250 um so I was a
bigger guy you know broader shoulders
and things so you could intimidate
people and that was very valuable in the
pit and John explained a little bit more
cuz there's a lot of people listening
who have no idea how the pits worked
especially back then and when you're
talking about it being more physical and
kind of the jockeying for positions and
things like that like unpack that a
little bit and explain what was
happening sir well um so you're in the
trading pit and a pit is an octagon just
like you know the UFC fights in except
they have steps that go up usually like
3 or 4 feet in the air each step is let
say you know six or eight inches so
there might be four steps up four steps
down into the middle of the pit and each
ring if you will of that pit is about 18
inches wide so you could stand on that
but it's not exactly like standing on a
2x4 there's enough room that you can
kind of walk around on it but you could
also fall off of it and you know so
sometimes when traders were standing in
their spot if all the sudden a trade was
happening on the other side of the pit
everybody would rush towards that side
of the pit
salt salt salt oh and they're stumbling
down the steps and things as they go
over to that side of the pit so the pits
are set up so that from the top ring of
the pit you can see all the trading
desks around the floor if you're down in
the middle of the pit you can't even see
out of the pit you're just looking at
guys bellies and things like that so the
more active trader you are you're at the
top and the less active you are or the
newer you are you're down at the bottom
so the guys at the bottom tended to hold
positions for a long time the guys that
want to buy so buy sell all day long
they're at the top and the brokers want
to stand next to the guy that's actively
trading because by rule they can't trade
against their own paper so if I have an
order from a customer I'm calling that
paper I cannot take the other side of
this trade I have two open outcry it
into the pit and say 55 calls and the
pitch screams back you know one to a
quarter and I can say I'll pay 115 and
then they might say at a quarter at a
quarter and a quarter and then if I
can't buy them at 1:15 and the order is
not held meaning I can pay any price I
want I might say a hundred and hundred I
bought 200 I'm out I'm 115 bid for 200
more or whatever so that trade would
happen with those two guys they'd all
right each other's names down on the pit
on the card rather the sellers would
write down who they sold to the buyer
would write who he bought from and then
they turn in their cards so all of this
got processed at the end of the day when
I started then as trading became faster
and faster and faster it eventually
moved to handheld computers then it
moved to you know at almost light speed
to laptops and then you don't need
traders on the floor anymore now you can
make that market pop from New York
from Philly or from Macau that doesn't
matter
so you don't need to be in the pits
anymore so the pits went from very
profitable places to be where you know
if there's 3,000 traders down there you
know they might be taken a couple
billion dollars home every year and all
of a sudden you know most of that gets
taken by high-frequency guys and now the
traders on the floor these days you know
if you're still on the floor maybe you
make a hundred hundred and fifty
thousand bucks instead of a couple
million or ten million whatever you
could make before and you multiply that
times you know two or three thousand so
you get where you know the the big
change came from now there's almost no
one on trading floors it's all by
machine yeah and it's only struck me at
the New York Stock Exchange for for
example there's still some people
walking around you look at the old
school photos compared to today and it's
your night/day difference it almost
feels like the people actually on the
floor are almost there is more of a
ceremonies type thing right where it
just feels like we gotta have somebody
that we can't just have servers all over
the floor so yeah let's I don't know
it'll put 50 people out there but but
what are they actually doing right are
they literally they're from more of a
ceremonious thing and they just person
it's their personal preference to be on
the floor and kind of just use your
computer from the floor or is there some
purpose other than that
well like the New York Stock Exchange
they have kept a couple of carve-outs
for the traders on the floor they see
certain information like the end of the
day when they say well on unbalance
there's two billion to buy or whatever
they see that first they know it before
anybody else now most of them are
filling paper meaning that they're
brokers they're not traders and that's
no disrespect but that's just what it is
you know they're they're not trading
they are brokers they're filling paper
so they're offering insights and best
you know I'm gonna try to get you the
best price you know and I've
relationship with this guy for ten years
so I think he's great at getting me the
best price and seeing blocks that might
come in getting out of the way and
letting it fall a little bit then he
buys it at a cheaper price for me that's
why they're still there but most of
those traders are brokers now the
exception is the options pits at the CME
they have corn options being options
wheat options all that kind of stuff you
kind of smile and it's like oh yeah yeah
I bet they're really I know they
actually still trade in those pits they
still have traders and brokers but most
of the other pits around the rest of the
world it's really just like you say
they've negotiated to keep themselves in
the mix so it's not just ceremonial but
there's really not as strong a purpose
for them to be there well I have some of
the commodity pits survived so things
like corn etc like why are they still
not only there but but also active
whereas others that have kind of gone
the way of more electronic trading I
think only by mandate I mean in other
words if if the exchange and the members
have a deal where they say hey we want
you know there to always be some open
outcry trading on the floor that's the
only reason it still goes on everything
else can be done on computer I'm not
saying it's better having for instance
as when the crap hit the fan in March
pump and all of a sudden whether you're
trading the SPS or whether you're
trading in the VIX pit when things are
blowing up you're better off having
everybody getting the information at the
same time in the pit then having
everybody in offices upstairs and
they're all suspicious because that's
what it is they're all suspicious then
they see an order coming in and they
don't know who it is when that comes in
on the floor and they can all see it at
the same time
they know that's coming in from JPMorgan
they know that's coming in from
Blackrock or whatever um but when it's
upstairs they you know it's silent it's
kind of like you know alien in space can
anybody hear you scream
I mean when a trade happens in the ether
there's nothing there's no information
at all it's just kind of like the trade
comes in people interact with it you
don't know how big it was you don't know
you know if it fell into a guy's lap
over on you know that you think is a
great trader or a guy that's a [ __ ]
trader and it falls into weak hands and
all of a sudden you know the market
moves just a little bit and everybody's
selling because this guy is scrambling
to sell out rather than if it falls into
somebody with strong hands meaning
they've probably got hundreds of
millions behind them or whatever and
they hold it for that 10 cent loss and
all the sudden it click click click
click click runs to the upside and
they're making dollars off of this you
know huge trade they took down you know
it makes a difference when you see it in
the pit it makes a difference when you
can't see it it's just silent and that's
when there's a lack of trust things that
I've noticed is people who started out
in the pits or got exposed to that world
when they were kind of really rocking
and rolling they have a very different
understanding of markets and market
structure and and it really seems like
they had access to understand the
importance of intangible type
information right so what I mean is you
know good traders first bad traders
who's actually sending in that market or
who does that person represent from a
training perspective how much capital is
behind them versus not right all that
type of stuff and it feels like now that
we've kind of gone into this electronic
world the people who have that kind of
historical context and information they
actually understand markets better right
they do have some level of advantage do
you see the same thing in your
experience or do you feel like maybe
that's just coming from somebody who I
wasn't around when the pits were really
kind of rocking and rolling like that
and so it's more of like a nostalgia
thing more so than anything else well I
think it's
it's definitely a skill pit trading
that's different and doesn't necessarily
translate that well to the you know
screen based trading because just like
you say if there's a Schwab broker on
that side of the pit and you know TD
broker on this side Merrill and you know
Lehman Brothers back in the day Bear
Stearns different brokers are
representing different paper so you know
coming through Schwab its retail you
know it's even though they might try to
mask it occasionally with you know a big
trader might come in through something
that they call a beard you know coming
through as a retail trade you know size
and how aggressive both the trade and
the broker are that it's something
different so in other words we all want
to trade with somebody who's slower than
us who doesn't have as much access to
information and that differential back
in the day was you know Grand Canyon
right because it really was it was huge
you would have guys that you know had
news flows that were faster guys that
you know we would get you know long
before news reading algorithms and
things like that
there were people that you know got
tipped off by somebody when news was
about to break as illegal as that might
sound now nobody's faster than the
algorithms the algorithm is going to see
keywords that somebody has programmed
for their IM sell programs to react to
and you see it and it happens like that
there's no way to get in front of
everything from the employment data to
the is em to Michigan you know consumer
confidence you know whatever it is so to
your point there were definitely people
that had that edge of whether it was
informational edge or whether it was
the ability to read you know to know the
difference between a wobbler door on the
side of the pit and a knee trade order
over there and you know that JP Morgan
you know order that's coming in for a
hedge fund and you don't want to be on
the other side of Bobby Axelrod so when
Bobby's coming in and he wants to buy a
lot of something you don't want to be on
that ticket you ought to be the last guy
on the Oh for instance that's what
Warren Buffett has done forever Warren
Buffett owns general reinsurance and
generally um is always the last one to
write that reinsurance ticket you know
everybody else has piled on there and
then the last 200 mil the last 500 mil
whatever it is is Warren Buffett you
know it's it's him doing that because
everybody else is taking the risk he
gets to look and you know if that
thing's not getting funded properly
those other guys are screwed he's not
smooth so anyway to your point the
democratization that has occurred with
information flows over Twitter which you
know there's not a lot of things Twitter
is good for quite frankly but one of the
things that Twitter is good for it's
information that's almost instantaneous
so if you want to see something if you
don't have a high speed data feed that
costs you 20,000 bucks a month
Twitter's the next best thing you gotta
know where to who to follow and how to
get it but it's there so if you're
looking for certain keywords and things
like that you will find them faster on
Twitter then you will do in a Google
search or anything else but do you
really want to try to trade against you
know basically ads that are much much
faster than you and my answer is no I
want to follow those guys and coattail
those guys that's why I always call what
we do following smart money but
I don't want to try to compete with
those guys that are always going to be
faster than me unless I want to spend a
hundred thousand bucks a month and then
have an IT staff you know the size of
Goldman's or vertues or drw or any of
these guys unless you can do that you're
not going to be as fast as that I think
it makes a ton of sense
help me understand what you guys are
doing with market rebellion so you had
it up on the zoom background and you
guys have been talking about it a lot
online and everything what is market
rebellion and what do you guys doing
with it they're happy to we are over at
market rebellion were basically using
the same sort of techniques that we used
to train people years ago that were our
own traders so in other words when you
came down to the floor and as I said if
you're a chess grandmaster or if you're
a card counter from Vegas and you learn
some of the basics of floor trading you
can start to you know understand how to
make markets you still have to be big or
at least aggressive and then you have to
know how to layoff risk and all these
other things and know how to cut your
losses
let the winners run so we trained
hundreds of our own traders over the
years and once they got good enough it
always leave you know as they used to be
kind of a joke they'd say Lincoln freed
slaves but you know when you're a trader
backing another trader there's no
greater compliment than that traitor
leaving you and going off on his own or
herl
because that means you really trained
them they know what they're doing and
none of us at least I never did try to
tie anybody up to a contract and say no
you've got to work for me for three
years that's that's crazy
but some people did it most of the time
what traders would do when we were
training a trader is I would
money for you up and I'd put up say 50
grand and I'd say okay you know you've
been working with us you understand what
you're doing I have confidence in you
here's 50 grand go out there and make us
some money and you go into the pit and
start trading and if you started losing
money really fast we'd cut you off but
if you know since we trained you we
taught you what to look for and all that
kind of stuff you probably started
making money and all sudden I give you
more and more money now eventually I've
given you a quarter of a million dollars
and you're making money once you've made
me my quarter million back I'm probably
on a like a 60/40 my way split on that
so when you make two hundred thousand
dollars you don't get two hundred
thousand I get a hundred and twenty you
get eighty kind of thing once we get to
you've paid me my 200 back now I'm like
okay pop I'll do a deal with you where
it's 64 your way and you're like okay
and now you're really grinding hard and
then you're making money and I say okay
now it's 70/30 your way and then
eventually you leave because you're
gonna say I want to make all the money
for me and I'm like yeah you should so
you're out there trading those when you
say what is market rebellion we took all
the same training that we used for our
traders and we basically systematized it
put it online and people can go through
a chapter by chapter and learn here's
how you'd manage risk here's how you'd
cut losses here's how you take profits
because you got to be pulling profits
off the table
just as aggressively as you're cutting
losses and then here are a bunch of
spreads here's a bunch of different ways
you can make more money and just
straight out scalping so market
rebellion is our version of what we use
to give our traders and we have basic
intermediate advanced we've got coaches
we've got
men towards you know depending on how
much time somebody's got they might just
learn at night cuz you know it's it's
just a distance-learning product they
can log on anytime they want watch it
for 20 minutes go put into the bed watch
it again whatever they've gotta pass a
test every chapter to get through it
and that's not so weak we don't get any
additional money but that's to make sure
you know what you think you know before
you move on because otherwise you know
you you could end up getting in trouble
instead of making money yeah absolutely
and so it feels a lot like you know
regardless of the assets trading for the
most part right a lot of the things
you're talking about is very systematic
right there's things around
understanding the market structure
understanding risk understanding when to
take profits off understanding options
you know all this type of stuff and and
do you feel like investors in general
not just ones who go through market
rebellion but but just investors in
general are kind of waking up to this
world of now there's the ability with
everything in fractional shares the zero
cost trading like more and more people
are saying hey look I want to do play in
the financial markets and there's more
access but they are seeking out that
type of education or you still have a
fear that there's so many people going
into the markets they just don't have
the not knowledge really necessary to to
set them up for success well I see both
and quite frankly through one of the
main things that you kind of identified
indirectly which is Robin Hood you know
one of the free trading place and you
know I admit when at first when I first
started to see a lot of the flow from
the Robin Hood type traders
I would somewhat dismissive up but
especially in light of kovat I've seen a
lot of smart and an edge and women that
are doing smart trades and this isn't
rocket science you know if it was I
wouldn't be doing it it's trading like
say is addictive it's fun
it's especially fun when you're when you
know enough how to not lose a lot
because that's what it's all about it's
not about making a lot it's about not
losing a lot because then when you have
the experience just as you know
obviously now you can lay into bigger
and bigger trades and feel more
confident about making money so for
instance Robin Hood well our business
has doubled every month of this covin
and I say that not because Pete and John
are so great and we've got a great staff
of men and women that work with us but
literally we have doubled in March in
April in May and in June doubled this is
the size of the business and I think pop
it's because you know I'm not on TV more
now than I was then I'm unless but I do
broadcast a lot I mean I put out my own
podcasts I do various you know reaches
to the public through you know Instagram
and all the rest but I don't think
that's it
I think that augments it but I think
there's a lot of people that are at home
at halftime and an awful lot of them are
really well versed in how to use the
internet so Robin Hood just being an app
because it's not really a trading
platform it's an app um and again that's
not meant to be derogatory and when I
say that but when you have a bunch of
people that are used to you know typing
with their thumbs and checking out their
phone all the time and they know how to
you know follow people on Twitter and on
Instagram and on snapchat and on tik-tok
even you know and they're getting all
this information many of those things I
just named you can get information damn
near instantaneous and so you've got a
guy like Davy day trader global right
you know you've got
Portnoy and a lot of these people
probably watch him and listen to him and
I should be a freaking comedian I mean
he is and he's a pretty good trader too
by the way I'm not just saying that you
know watching what he does and how he
does it I'd say he's a pretty good
little trait and he's self-taught from
what I can tell and I love the way he
goes after Buffett and me probably I
haven't heard that but you know he I
could easily see him you know I've got
the tie on cuz I just came off of CNBC
but you know he hates the suits he's
always talking about how freakin suits
they think they know everything
some 94 year old guy in Omaha know that
I don't know nothing you know I know
numbers I know you know airline seats
you know he's just I love him but I
think a lot of that entices the folks
that are that are at home and that are
watching him and they're kind of
chuckling tender kind of also seeing wow
you know he's talking about carnival and
it's up two bucks today you know that's
20% for a ten dollar stock or whatever
wonder if I could make some money
trading in Robin Hood so let me go in
there and like you say fractional chairs
oh you don't have enough for a hundred
chairs there's 20 chairs there's one
chair and they kind of learn it and
they're getting the hang of it and you
know I'm sure there are some spectacular
losses because there always are like I
said in a professional environment like
down on the trading floor we would turn
over almost a third every year and most
of it isn't people that are leaving
because they got rich you know they're
leaving because they couldn't hack
couldn't take the pressure and take the
losses lost a backer whatever it might
be you know they couldn't do it so to
think that you probably have about the
same from people at home home gamers as
we call you know people that are trying
to trade and make a living but it's it's
also one of the things that I've
observed forever
is that I want to make you know 100
grand a year 200 and it all and out of
bed because I've done it for a while so
it's not hard you know and think about
that if I want to make 200 grand a year
there are 256 trading days in a year so
I only have to net you know let's say
what 7 800 bucks a day if you can't do
that sitting in front of your computer
all day moving the odds in your favor
you know you're at a blackjack table
it's the way we always tell our traders
you're at a blackjack table don't have
to accept you don't have to bet you
don't have to put even you know the you
don't have to ante anything you can just
sit there and sit there and say I'm
waiting I'm waiting I'm waiting and all
the sudden you're you've been counting
the shoe and the dealer's got a bunch of
face cards in there and you're like okay
I'm in buying 500 shares of Carnival I'm
buying 500 shares of Apple I'm buying a
thousand shares of Facebook whatever it
is and all sudden those things because
of setup you think you saw that is
actually working now all sudden that
thousand tears of Facebook Facebook
moves a point and a half
you just made 1,500 bucks so now the
deal is are you smart enough or are you
too greedy you only needed to make 700 a
day to get to your two hundred thousand
you know quarter of a million goal so
that freaking money off the table or at
least take most of it off the table
carnival starting to move for you or
against you cut it or add to it or
whatever but again keep in mind you were
there to make your fifth you know your
seven hundred or a thousand bucks you
don't have to push it to three or four
thousand if you can do that you're
talking about six hundred thousand eight
hundred thousand a year but if your goal
was two hundred and now you're pushing
it and maybe you're out on the ragged
edge because you're leveraged you know
you're in margin and bad knows
your world you know you could be you
know getting fifty to one leverage on
you know various digital assets and on
the options on those digital deficits
which is no risk on crack you know you
could do all that but is that the right
thing in other words I think there are
plenty of people who end to it and
there's a lot of people who get enticed
into or fool themselves into thinking
yeah I I I'm Davy day trader global you
know five thousand a day if I do five
thousand a day I'm making a million a
year and all of a sudden you know the
market reverses and they're sitting
there and they're going oh my god no I
was up fifteen hundred and I pushed for
five and now I'm down three thousand
that means that Adam make you know four
days worth of seven hundred just to get
back to break-even as long as they're
disciplined they can win in this game
but there will be a lot of that will
lose because they don't have the disk
they it's a great way to look at it is
just breaking it down into kind of day
by day and again going back to kind of
how we started the conversation about
just showing up every day right in and
out and understanding and believing in
and enjoying that process you you and
your brother and number people around
you have become very big or maybe not
big but I've become more excited about
Bitcoin and digital assets and have
started to actually make investments in
the space so maybe just talk us through
kind of how you guys evaluate Bitcoin in
the crypto markets in light of kind of
the rest of your portfolio and then what
you guys have done in the crypto space
sure well I probably got somewhere
between and on an on a monthly basis
because I don't trade that often I'm not
like in and out in and out during the
day like you up but on a monthly basis I
probably have between five and ten
percent in digital assets and almost all
of its Bitcoin a little aetherium but
mostly Bitcoin I've got a little light
coin a little stone
but really I'm about Bitcoin and I'm
aired because guys like yourself guys
like Peter Brit over at fortress who
really got me you know psyched about it
Max Keiser always likes to tell me oh
yeah I told John to buy at this I love
you max but I don't remember you telling
me to buy it when it was freaking 40 you
probably pulled a bunch of people but
you didn't tell me I woulda loved it if
you did but I love max I mean he's a
funny dude and he you know randomly pop
he will put out a tweet that says and
told all these guys and he'll list like
10 of us to buy Bitcoin at 40 bucks or
whatever and I'm like okay whatever I
wish you did because if you did I'd be
rich but I first got involved in about
300 realized I didn't know what the hell
I was doing in it didn't get involved
again until it was closer to 1700 so I
missed an awful lot of that and I didn't
sell when I got over 18 or 19 thousand I
didn't liquidate I would have looked
like a genius if I did but then we all
would I right now Pete and I put an
investment down and Voyager you know a
crypto broker run by a friend of ours
Steve early and or a bunch of smart
investors that got into this latest
round - so I wanted to get in because I
think these other investors are smart I
think Steve is doing building the
business in a good way and you know I've
met so many so for instance I know a
lady that runs the Winklevoss family
office great lady's smart woman Stanford
grad I think she's a Kaos mathematician
and you know I think what the wincle
vibe did buying into the
you know buying into Bitcoin in a big
way and getting involved in the space
creating Gemini and all that this is all
good stuff for the space the way I look
at no Novogratz Peter Berger and these
guys fortress Pantera you know all of
these different groups that have come in
and bigger and bigger ways I I don't
think they've wrecked it I think they've
made it and I think that it'll you know
it still just got a foothold that's this
big compared to everything else
compared to gold compared to stocks
compared to futures but I I think that
people will you know it and again
nothing better than kovat popped for
people to realize no it hasn't hurt the
dollar yet but eventually what we're
doing printing money is gonna hurt the
doll and it's gonna hurt my kids
it's gonna hurt you know for years out
into the future all this printing of
additional capital and that's what I
love about digital assets like Bitcoin
you know I love that it's it would
really have to be a mutually assured
destruction for us to have more bitcoins
than the toki Nakamoto Satoshi and
whoever in that group or that whatever
is it created as as the the top level of
the amount of bitcoins out there you
know it would take a majority of us that
own coins to say yeah let's let's make
more and I don't think that's in the
cards for sure it and make it part of
this and what's really interesting is we
kind of have two forces at work here
right you have kind of the bullishness
and the market growth and the innovation
that's happening in Bitcoin and the
crypto markets and that by itself I
think it's you know a good amount of
people excited but then you bring up the
other point which is and then you have
the traditional world absolutely
in chaos right and yes the stock market
is hitting all-time highs and yeah
there's people who base to saying hey
look I know the world is basically
burning but I'm making money right so
there's kind of this cognitive
dissonance if you will but at the same
time it's only going up right as
Portenoy would say because of the
structural thing of we're just injecting
trillions of dollars into the market so
of course you're going to get the
inflation of asset prices do you feel
like the damage to the dollar is that
more something short-term you're worried
about medium-term long-term like how do
you think about when that damage
actually kind of comes and it sounds
like you're of the belief that Bitcoin
would be kind of a bit of fishery of
some of that kind of collateral damage
to some degree yeah well and you'd be
much more eloquent speaker about the
topic but here's some of the things that
I have heard from folks like you and
from you that I think play into that so
longer-term yes I think it does impact
not in the short term short term were a
safe haven just like Japan is a safe and
still prints more money than we do you
know borrows a ton and yet people
haven't abandoned their currency it's
just the opposite because such a country
of savers and so forth I think one of
the things that probably hits Bitcoin in
a positive way pomf beyond you know that
we're printing money and it's making
other currencies worth less
again like Buffett says not worthless
worth less is that I think we're likely
to see people get frustrated by things
you know could be Biden supporters could
be Trump supporters it could be BLM
could be a whole bunch of things that
have caused people to say you know what
I don't know if I want especially like
here in Chicago where are you right now
are you in New York
I am yep in New York okay so New York
and Chicago
they burned our cities and they you know
I'm not saying I'm not blaming the cops
but I'm saying the cops were told to
stand down I believe in both cities and
then they burned up and down Lexington
and Madison and they were obviously down
on Fifth Avenue and destroying things in
New York where I love to spend time
destroying things here in Chicago up and
down Michigan Avenue and we know that
wasn't the you know peaceful protesters
that was more or less career criminals
that just used it as cover for them to
do what they do but I think it woke a
lot of people up and a lot of people
realized that there's going to be a lot
of stress on the system and maybe they
want to get somewhere other than where
we are and the most portable wealth on
the planet is Bitcoin it is the most
portable because all you'd have to do is
to have it up here you don't have to
back in the day before there was Bitcoin
comp it would be might hear this from my
friends in Israel or I'd hear it from
friends in the Middle East and they'd
tell me I bought a bunch of American
Express travelers decks remembered the
serial number on the first and the last
and I burned them burned them why
because now I can go anywhere and then
walk into the American Express office in
Geneva Switzerland and say here's the
here's my American Express traveler's
checks here's the first here to the last
you know they got destroyed give me my
money and they would but you're giving
up you know 3% or 4% to do that trade
and meanwhile in Bitcoin you can be
dumping back and forth from going to
stable coin and doing all kinds of
things while you're trading these other
currencies and jumping back and forth
into its stable point or whatever
without even taking the market will
discover the Bitcoin and move anywhere
you want with your money if you're well
and that I view as a constant demand
feature the more people to figure that
out and I know you and everybody who's
been a longtime
Bitcoin or digital asset proponent they
have said forever yeah you know how do
you take my Bitcoin you know you can't
you can't take my but you can screw with
my bank account you can basically put an
exit tax on me if I want to leave
America or you know leave the country
and give up my citizenship and go over
to Switzerland to go to Italy or go to
wherever but if you have Bitcoin they
can't do that I mean you could literally
go anywhere on the planet no I'm not
saying that there's lots of places
better than America but I'm saying it's
it's a nice insurance policy to have
something that is portable wealth and it
doesn't have to be like when my
great-grandfather came here because of a
genocide of Armenians
he came here with bags filled with gold
he wasn't that rich but you know
obviously gold back then versus what it
is now he would have been crazy rich
because gold wasn't seventeen or
eighteen hundred dollars an ounce but he
had literally bags of gold heavy to
transport you know pretty significant
risk of theft and all the rest meanwhile
Bitcoin nobody knows you have it I loved
when I would travel back and forth in
Europe over the last couple of years and
I'd be at the border and the guy would
say anything to declare
you know over 10,000 in currency or
whatever and I'm like nope and yet you
got whatever I mean you know could be
tens of millions of dollars and Bitcoin
and nobody's the wiser
just words in your brain that's how it
works
one of the things is it feels like Wall
Street's waking up to a lot of this
right and so there's the kind of
qualitative argument how I described
why bitcoins important you just did a
great job of articulating it and you
don't give yourself enough credit for
understanding kind of the intricacies of
it
but then there's also more and more
investors who seem to say hey look wait
a second this is a tradable asset as
well
so we've seen you know renaissance
technologies obviously putting one of
their filings that they're now looking
at Bitcoin account actually Muirfield
was spot trading or our kind of options
type trading we've seen Paul Tudor Jones
come out and say he's put about 2% of
his portfolio into Bitcoin and and so
we're kind of like now okay there's more
comfort cover-your-ass going on right
there there's more people with big names
and great track records that are
starting to actually get exposure to
Bitcoin do you think that that really
wakes up Wall Street and we're gonna see
this like massive capital inflow or do
you think it's still something that just
slowly but surely over time more and
more people will opt into it it's just
gonna take you know three four or five
years to happen and I I don't have that
crystal ball tom so I don't know but I
do know that all those people you named
as well as a friend of mine Marc Lasry
Merck is a distressed asset buyer that's
what he does
so he finds distressed assets and buys
him now he's not saying that bitcoin is
a distressed asset he's saying I put I
think he said two to five percent of his
net worth and it's in the billions into
digital assets Bitcoin being the most
prominent I think and I think you'll see
more and more of those folks doing that
I mean I got a belief done alton who is
such a proponent of gold and you know
famously caught the financial crisis and
out on the right side of that and then
he got in bold and since then he's kind
of you know sort of said now i'm
shutting it down I'm just gonna run my
family office I guarantee you he gets
into Bitcoin if he isn't already but I
think a lot of who will want to keep it
quiet as they're getting in because you
know they'll run it
I don't mean that they'll run it and in
terms of how it operates I mean they'll
push the price too far too fast so for
the exact same guys that know that you
don't want Goldman knowing that you're
buying you know fireEye or uber or
Microsoft because they'll run it ahead
of you those same guys are sitting there
thinking I really like this playing
Bitcoin here but I'm not gonna say a lot
about it until I got enough of the stuff
because you know you both know that
blocks of it stand out and so they've
got to stay under the radar with these
accumulations and forever I had pop guys
coming to me two years ago I probably
had five to ten calls a week from people
telling me oh I want to buy 200 million
in Bitcoin and I'd say no you don't and
they'd say oh yeah I do I I'll give you
proof of funds and all that and as soon
as I'd ask for it then they didn't have
you know same old crap and it was when
Bitcoin was falling from 18 on down to
35 or 3,200 whatever and it seemed like
more than anything they were trying to
hold the price level by telling people
like me that they had it I so I would go
to people and then these you know that
had large quantities and these people
would say okay give me proof of funds
I'll do 50 million or I'll do 100
million with him and bla bla bla and
these were at four and five thousand
dollars per Bitcoin USD to Bitcoin and I
did I think two transactions out of at
least a hundred and most of them were
complete BS and I think they were just
trying to you know manipulate the market
or whatever the same is true when it's
you know stabilized and hanging near ten
thousand now the people are probably not
wanting to see it dump to 12 and 15 and
28 down to
fast because they're gonna try to
accumulate it at a level that's exactly
what's happening you you understand that
the people who want to buy a lot don't
want the price to go up right now and
that's what we're seeing before I wrap
up I always ask people the same two
questions and then you're gonna get to
ask me one to finish it the first is
what is the most important book that
you've ever read one of the most
important would be I'm Rand and I don't
mean the Fountainhead but John Galt
I just love you know I know not
everybody's a big fan of libertarianism
and you can be you know I know Alan
Greenspan was an Atlas Shrugged is one
of you know those books that sort of
changed my outlook I mean for a long
time pop I start the book and couldn't
finish it and some of that is because
I'm Dyslexic so I I don't enjoy reading
but I enjoy books so now all I do as far
as books I read newspapers because you
know I have to or you know online stuff
because I have to but as far as a book
now I listen to them all on tape so I
love it because I can do it when I'm
walking when I'm working out when I'm
flying in a plane you know driving a
long drive or whatever I love it so that
was my best way to get through Atlas
Shrugged because it is you know a lot to
get through but I I loved a lot of what
she wrote and how passionate she was
about it and the Greenspan was such a
big fan and then after going through it
twice now I'd say that's probably the
book for me that I would
that's a great answer and I'm the almost
100% audiobooks as well so I'm there
with you the second question is more fun
aliens believer or non-believer believer
why so I I believed that I saw some
activity that I could not describe any
other way except to say it was alien
because I was coming out of an artist
studio in college and because a girl was
screaming outside so I was coming to her
rescue
being a gallant young lad so I came out
and she's pointing up in the sky like
this and it was about 2:00 in the
morning nobody else was around and I
looked up at what she is pointing at and
it was you know as many have said a
cigar shaped object that was lit up and
I couldn't tell how far away it was and
I'm sitting there looking at it what the
hell is that and we're both just staring
at it she wasn't screaming anymore and I
said how long has it been there and she
said it's been there for like three or
four minutes it's just sitting there and
it appeared to be over a building that
was about maybe an eighth of a mile to a
quarter of a mile away not too far and
we couldn't tell how big it was from
that distance but it had a steady glow
not late going around it or anything
just a steady glow and wasn't in a
balloon or anything else stayed at that
exact spot and then all of a sudden pop
it just went you know like back and
forth like this Oh straight up and gone
um and so we were both just what the
hell was that now flash forward to a Joe
Rogan pod it's not as popular as pop and
I'll run it up there so I'm listening to
this Navy pilot talk about seeing the
same tic-tac shaped thing you know cigar
Tic Tac whatever out over the ocean
about I think four or five hundred miles
off the coast of California and he's
talking about he's pinging it on radar
and it's not there and you know his
copilot you know the guy behind him the
weapons officer or whatever behind him
is gone
I got nothing on it skipper and he's
going he says all of a sudden then it
starts jamming them and he said in the
rodent podcast I believe he said
jamming us is an act of war he said if
you're jamming you know our planes when
they're out there to defend an aircraft
carrier it was just a routine trip but
he is out there and he says if you're
actively jamming us and said that's an
act of war so he says we go close to
this thing now as he said I'm you know
thousands of feet above it at this point
but he said we go right down at it he
said it is down on the watch just above
the water and there's something beneath
the water that he says looks like it
might be controlling it or something and
it's a big thing you know like the size
of the submarine or bigger
under the water and all of a sudden this
little Tic Tac II thing that he's got
video of it but he's got no radar back
from it's being blocked or absorbed or
whatever all of a sudden he says thing
just goes at a speed of light but faster
than anything he says that any object
that we know that can fly cannot move
this fast and he said it just goes
straight up and gone and he and the
copilot are just like what the hell was
that
and he gets back to the ship and they
say you were chasing UFOs again huh huh
captain and he goes yep and they go you
see any and he throws him the VHS tape
but he was you
me and the Navy has released that tape
and scary it is seeing there is
something out there my friend listen I
believe her I don't know if they've come
here if they're not but there's things
that we can't explain and the math
suggests that uh but they're out there
somewhere yeah
well so then my question to you would be
have you you know no sorry I've never uh
never seen aliens the reason why I asked
the question is again by the way I
haven't seen aliens yeah is evidence of
a ship or a vehicle of some sort I can't
explain how it got there or how it moves
yeah and the reason actually why I came
up with the question this is now almost
two years ago when I was laying in bed
one day and I literally was thinking do
aliens have pets which is a weird
question to think about but if you think
if somebody came here they back wait a
second so the big animals have smaller
animals on leashes and that live with
them right and can all this stuff and
like we just think of them as pets but
does that mean that there's like a
multi-species
alien you know kind of civilization out
there and they've literally some of the
aliens are kind of in charge or more
intelligent and they've got texts of you
know other things certain is thinking
about that like we have no clue we
literally have no clue and and saying
you just like you can get lost thinking
about all this stuff and one of it is
just fun right - is it's kind of just
like intellectual curiosity exercise but
it just does feel like we'd be pretty
selfish to think that we're here alone
yeah and the more you see you know again
people credible people like that Navy
pilot he's got a lot more credibility
than me and he's seen a lot of weird
stuff I'm sure when you're up in the
atmosphere as often as those guys are
just like some of the astronauts are now
admitting that they've seen stuff up
there there's stuff you just can't
explain now could there be another
explanation for it now but to see it
that close
and to see him move that fast without a
sound again and he said they were
putting it even that Pilate was saying
we had it on infrared nothing there's no
exhaust plume there's nothing coming off
of this thing and he's like how the hell
is it moving
you know raisi now absolutely nuts John
where can people find you on the
internet and where where can they find
Morgan Rebellion
oh you can go to market rebellion calm
and it's just like the name sounds
market rebellion calm forward-slash get
started that's all of our educational
stuff and if they want to follow me on
twitter just at Jo n na jay-ar I am just
add Jon Najarian your legend my friend
thank you Samar thank you saw yeah
listen thank you for doing this I think
that you know people get a see on TV
every day and kind of see everything
that you're talking about so it's
awesome to kind of hear your thoughts
both about you know your background a
story but also how you look at Bitcoin
and digital assets so thank you so much
for taking the time to do this thanks
very much pop I appreciate the offer
sure